you start by focusing on what you have
and not what you don't have but if you
spend your time thinking about all the
things you don't have you're done or the
successful entrepreneurs focus on what
they can do with what they do have so
you take whatever idea you have and it's
amazing to think about how big it is but
then what can you do right now like
today after this to start working on it
question will be I'm thinking about like
partnership and that partnership make it
simpler to do business or it's better to
be a lone wolf okay that's a tough one
there's no there's no right or wrong
answer should you be a partner or should
you go solo having a partner is like
getting married so if you're in a great
marriage it's awesome and if you know
crappy marriage it sucks
yeah and so most people pick the wrong
person to partner with at the beginning
mm-hmm
most people look at it just on a skills
base so you know you're great at doing
this and you suck at doing this I need
to find a partner who does this right
you don't want to people do the exact
same thing you need to balance should
there of the real test is going to be
can you grow and learn together so it
may be great at the beginning but
especially being so young - you have
interests and you're evolving and you
want to go down this path and you want
to study this and if they're not
interested in that stuff and they want
to go this other way pretty soon you got
this big gap between what you both are
interested in and the thing falls apart
just like in marriages I think what
makes a successful relationship is your
ability to evolve together can you can
you Zig and zag together as you grow as
a human like what you were interested in
five years ago is not the same as now
and won't be the same in five years yeah
awesome
can that partner's stay with you for
that journey or not and most of the time
it's not but most of times because you
didn't do a good job in finding the
right person at the beginning you have
similar values not just skills that
match right so you met this guy at your
school
you know maybe in five usually hate them
you know who knows you might be on doing
something else right but like you're
running this parallel path right now but
can you continue to run that as you go
off here does he want to come with you
and can you go like this together or
just which is okay but you can't be here
and be partner still but anyways we made
this path together
yeah help each other yeah yeah yeah and
so that's it's great to have people in
your life who you're running like even
now this is a parrot we're we're on a
parallel path together for the next you
know 40 minutes here we're over long
we're gonna do this great yeah I'm gonna
go out here and maybe maybe I'll see you
again at some point you're gonna tell me
your story and we'll connect again or
maybe I never see you ever again right
so but while we're doing our parallel
paths we want it to be the best possible
use of our time and then we'll see where
things go so the danger with the
partnerships if you're forming a natural
business and you have business partners
in there a lot of times when they start
diverging like this they don't do a good
job of communicating it then they get
into big fights they let the gap get too
big and then this is super destructive
thing that you don't want to have happen
so it's thinking about yes I want
somebody who complements my skill sets
but more important is do we share
similar values and can we continue to
run paths together right yeah so I have
an idea right now okay I don't have a
team I don't have mentor I don't have
Network okay
what do i do first what do I who should
I met first okay so - so process you
start by focusing on what you have and
not what you don't have mm-hmm so you
don't have a lot of stuff awesome great
I still don't have a lot of stuff that
could help me get to where I want to go
but if you spend your time thinking
about all the things you don't have your
done or the successful entrepreneurs
focus on what they can do with what they
do have this advice from Steve Wozniak
the co-founder of Apple it's like don't
focus on what you don't have instead
think about what you can do with what
you do have
so I'm thinking about when I was 19 at
my first business I focus on the things
that I didn't have where I was selling
to researchers only to scientists and a
lot of them were three times my age I
had all these PhDs
like well they're never gonna want to
talk to a young person and I was always
afraid to talk to them or go to events
because it just focus on what I didn't
have yeah
or instead you think okay what how can I
use what I have because people your age
often say well I'm too young I'm too
young I'm too young and then and then
they suddenly become too old I'm too old
and was like when were you ever the
right age Yeah right you're never the
right age you always to something it's
always some excuse right it's just fear
it's all just fear so if you want to get
a team you can go build a team if you
want to have a mentor you can go find a
mentor the biggest thing is whatever
your idea is it's great to have a big
mission big vision I want to solve this
giant problem awesome that's what can
get you motivated in the morning and
find the smallest possible way to get
started so what a lot of times happens
is people build up this giant idea but
then to make it work you need a team and
you need mentors you need venture
capital and you need all this stuff and
then it's just crazy scary thing that's
never gonna happen yeah and the idea
dies with you we're instead think about
the big idea but then what can I do
right now with what I have so you know
you mentioned Richard Branson being one
of your heroes when he started in the
airline industry you know the story of
his first yeah right it's like there's a
stranger on some Island and the only way
to get off was to charter a plane so he
said okay guys like who wants to get off
the island with me you're gonna charter
a plane and he sold tickets and he
chartered the plane exactly like that
day he did it great so the faster you
can go from idea to action idea the
action idea to actions when you start
winning so you take whatever idea you
have and it's amazing to think about how
big it is but then what can you do right
now animal like today after this to
start working on it if you can learn
just to go from I have an idea I'm going
to do something right now about it and
it's gonna suck yeah and then I'm gonna
Kaizen it up to be amazing then you win
for everything absolutely yeah like one
of my biggest regrets of all time was I
was in I was in Paris I was I was 18 I
was 18 in Paris because the year before
I did my business and this girl came up
and asked me for directions
outside the notre-dame Cathedral in
Paris and she had in you know in she had
a French accent and I wanted to ask her
out and it didn't actually likewise this
girl who's knows French asking me for
directions didn't wig
anyway I was too I was too afraid to ask
her I said hey you want to grab a coffee
or something I was just too shy too
embarrassed to whatever so I just told
her how to get to wherever she want to
go and and and then she she left you
know I was like come on man fruit oh so
then I I took a picture of that area I
tried to get her in the picture but she
was she walked too far away and I
printed a picture and put it on my wall
at home as a reminder to not live with
regret that if I want to do something
even if I was afraid cuz yeah I'm just
afraid of rejection like maybe she says
no no that kills me yeah okay but I'd
rather know than not know I can deal
with the failure but I can't deal with
not knowing yeah and so I put that on my
wall and then I said the next time
something happens that I might regret
then then I have to go off and do that
thing because it's very real of the
things that you do that you regrets
think you don't do things I could have
done that but I didn't do it I regret it
so I put that on my wall and in the next
year when I was 19 I had a chance to
join a startup company as one of the
owners and it was a choice between that
and getting the job what I thought was
my dream job and making lots of money
and traveling the world and all that
kind of stuff
and the easy answer would be to go take
the job but I thought about the regret
situation and I don't know if I'll ever
get this chance again
so I have to go off and do that thing
and so like staring at that picture
every day was a reminder that the next
time it comes I'm gonna have to go off
and do the thing even if I'm afraid so
my first business could have failed and
it almost
but at least I would know at least I
would know wherever women got a job I'd
be always thinking what if I just joined
that startup you know like what if I
join that startup where would I be
so minimize regrets so if you end up
just don't repeat the same thing if some
girl comes in ask for directions and you
want to ask her out
thank you for coffee and see where it
goes absolutely yeah this is an amazing
thing when you do something in order to
not regret losing the chance yeah well
even like come in here right
Xavier vez maybe you're scared the
others lights and cameras everywhere
Danis is pretty scary dude you know it
it's a a lot of people don't say yes
because they're afraid where they sit at
home and complain about not getting
mentorship and not you know taking
action and all this but then like he was
a chance yeah and it may be that it may
be great like maybe you get some from
this and you apply that to your life or
maybe it's the worst thing of all time
like maybe maybe I'm an ass and I kick
you out and you get nothing from it
right but the result isn't as important
as the effort that you said I'm you you
say awesome job because I did the thing
that I was scared to do regardless of if
the result was fantastic or not yeah you
were nervous you did it awesome
every time you nervous do it right and
and not everything will work out not
every girl you're a scouts gonna say yes
but you're nervous you did it that's
that's the win and you'll get you keep
doing that you'll get you'll get the
victory to get the results yeah this
interview was done as a part of my
Toronto workshop if you want more
details on the next one to sign up check
out the link right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there